oh my mom's Aurora Sleeping Beauty we
know what you're really all about Audrey
glamour titles royal events and
appearances it's all you really care
about you had your entire life planned
out before Mao came around and stole
your golden ticket this is Audrey
princess Audrey girlfriend you are going
to be the queen of auradon but now
you're just the queen of mean things
could be worse though right
and close and then everybody looks good
in my view oh and by the way Audrey
we're digging your new look
Audrey's got her poker face down pat but
what is she really up to Audrey's royal
return is filled with tiny clues that
are easy to miss watch until the end to
find out who Audrey might be working
with Audrey hates magic when it comes to
blabbing to her hairdresser Audrey goes
the extra mile she spilled some serious
tea while getting a makeover and we now
know that she absolutely hates magic
Audrey made it clear that she believes
magic to be the reason why Ben dumped
her I'll cast a love spell on Ben and
well she isn't exactly wrong now did put
Ben under a love spell to win him over
but she didn't use spells to keep him
around Audrey doesn't get why the vks
are so obsessed with magic in her eyes a
queen doesn't need magic to rule Audrey
doesn't want the bee case in auradon
another thing that Audrey made
abundantly clear is her disdain for the
villain kids I try to warn Ben about
bringing BK's over from the Isle of the
Lost but unfortunately for her no one
listened Audrey thinks they're dangerous
sneaky and power-hungry hmm remind you
of anyone Audrey doesn't really love
Chad surprise surprise the queen of mean
has zero feelings for Prince Chad
charming but in case you were wondering
Audrey did have real feelings for Ben at
the beginning of her rant Audrey reveals
that she thinks King Ben is super dreamy
she obviously still has feelings for him
but his dating Chad to keep up with
appearances Audrey only wants to date
people from Royal bloodlines
Audrey's extremely jealous of mal Audrey
might be dating Chad but she has every
intention of winning king Ben back
she's going to drastic lengths to get
him to notice her Audrey was super angry
when mouth started using her spell book
to give people makeovers in descendants
but now
Audrey's changing her hair to blonde and
adding colored highlights she's so
jealous of Mao that she's trying to look
exactly like her chillin like a villain
Audrey might pretend to be a pretty pink
princess but she's got some tricks up
her sleeve why else would the
instrumental version of chillin like a
villain be playing in the background
during her big reveal
Audrey definitely looks gorgeous but her
pristine look isn't fooling anybody
she's on her way to becoming a villain
and she's totally in denial and it's
gonna be sorry you ever let this go Oh
Audrey you have so much left to learn
audrey has an informant
Audrey misses auradon so much that she's
ready to come back home but she's
convinced that auradon misses her too we
know that Audrey's best friends are Jane
and Lonny or at least they used to be
Audrey makes fun of Jane during her
rants saying that Jane botched the
decorations without me match but if
there's one clue we couldn't help but
pick up on its that audrey has a special
informant someone told her everything
that happened in d2 but who could this
person be
what's my name Audrey obviously has a
friend on the other side how else would
she know what went down on the Isle of
the lost in descendants - Audrey
mentions uma throughout the trailer so
we're guessing that she might have made
a deal with a vengeful pirate
Audrey says that uma might be the only
girl in the world who hates mal more
than she does so if Audrey's looking to
form an alliance why not pick Emma's
brain after all the enemy of your enemy
is your friend right now got bangs now
it's just the bad girl infatuation
yeah I mean he's never gonna make a
villain Audrey loves to laugh at people
and hates it when they look better than
her
so his mal gets a makeover you best
believe that Audrey's going to get an
even better one
Audrey makes fun of mal for trusting a
bratty little VK with her hair she
laughs at the fact that now got bangs Oh
Myles worst enemy might be yourself did
you guys notice how evil Audrey looked
when she was laughing at now if she
isn't a villain in the making we don't
know what she is the queen of mean where
are we the only ones who felt super bad
for Audrey's beautician we mean she
talked her ear off the entire time and
still managed to boss her around more
sparkles
Audrey talks about how she chose to
behave herself at the end of the first
Descendants film because well she's a
princess with a reputation to protect
but that's never stopped her from being
mean to others yeah
real classy Audrey Ben likes bad girls
Audrey dropped some major clues
throughout the trailer she spoke about
all the trauma she faced the humiliation
she had to endure and how her
ex-boyfriend has a thing for bad girls
she obviously sees herself as a good
girl but she's about to snap we know for
a fact that Audrey is going to snap when
Ben proposes to Mouse despite saying
that she would never use magic to become
the queen of auradon we reckoned this is
exactly what Audrey is going to do she
might be a pretty pink princess but
she's got villain written all over her
face Audrey might be evil but she's
pretty funny our favorite part of
Audrey's royal return was when she
talked about dude the dog oh and
apparently the dog talks now what was
your favorite part
tell us in the comments for more videos
about your favorite Disney Channel
movies and characters subscribe to the
things and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]